Democrat Katie Porter probably best
known for allegedly dumping scalding
mashed potatoes on her ex-husband's
scalp cool is causing controversy again
this time she's taking her aggression
out on Republican women and saying
Republican lawmakers don't count when it
comes to leveling the playing field in
Congress Porter saying this quote to me
equality is not electing Joni Ernst like
that's not helping
is that not helping Jessica
I like the accent that you did that with
like a lady vibe to it
um
I we've talked about this issue before
it comes up every time that like Melania
doesn't get the cover of Vogue and they
say well she's the most stylish first
lady let's say since Jackie oh why
wouldn't you be on the cover of Vogue
and then I say
it's because her politics are not what
people feel who are in Media or
certainly Democrats are properly
supportive of women or help women lead
better lives so I wish that Katie Porter
had said for instance
I wish that Joni Ernst would support
raising the minimum wage I wish Joni
Ernst would support Paid Family Leave I
wish Joni Ernst would advocate for women
to be able to have the ability to make
decisions about their bodies if they're
going to have an abortion or not those
are the kinds of issues that she is
talking about beneath the service but it
seems like this flipped comment where
you're just kind of pushing it off I
will also say though even though
Republic the Republican agenda is not
for me
I get excited when a woman gets elected
like when Amy Coney Barrett got
confirmed to the Supreme Court
I was excited about it I think that any
step towards more gender Equity is
moving in a positive direction but it is
about the issues it is not about just
throwing someone you know a name like
Joni Ernst well that was a very honest
thing to say and I respect that hero
okay so how does she get to talk about
equality when she's the one currently
trying to prevent a black woman from
being the first black woman elected to
the Senate
and uh she would be a store candidate
you know what the first question I would
ask her is what is a woman can you tell
us Katie nope I don't think anybody has
the answer on the left Dana what do you
think about this kerfuffle among the
babes well it's uh it's yes part of this
whole thing that if you are a
conservative woman you need not apply
you don't get invited to the women's
conferences you don't get the you go
girl stamp of approval you just have to
work harder and make your points without
ever expecting to be on the cover of a
magazine with some fluffy puff piece no
you're going to get trashed and what you
have to do is make sure that you are on
the merits winning at every single step
of the way she also fired a staff member
who got covid berated her publicly and
was basically just tossed her out and
wants wants to be this candidate for
California for what like who are you
representing I don't I I really really
dislike this and I try not to do it
myself I also think that women have made
so many strives strides that we actually
don't need to do this anymore you look
at this upcoming debate who are the two
moderators me and Ilya Caldo Calderon
along with Stuart Varney who are the
White House Press secretaries who are
the cabinet secretaries who are some of
the candidates that are doing well it's
women so we have made great strides
let's just keep doing it and not to talk
about it all the time and what a
perfectly
bad waste of mashed potatoes Greg yes I
was just thinking that they're delicious
they are really I like them when they
have little lumps in them yeah me too to
use them as a weapon is just so it's
terrible I think this has to do
primarily with women who are pro-life
yep you know whenever you do uh you hear
uh uh pro-choice uh the Democrat talk
about pro-lifers they look down on them
and I keep trying I I've been trying to
think of a method of persuasion for if
you are pro-life
that you can talk to a pro-choicer about
without using the word murder because
that's where it all ends it's like it's
murder it's not murder so uh permission
to talk about abortion that might upset
people because I'm a man more people are
just me just you okay I I believe that
abortion for a lot of people and this is
rape and incest accepted is an act of
avoidance
um it's an avoidance is never having to
experience what it's like to have a
child the truth is abortion avoids that
transformational change from being a
sink a single uh or a childless person
to a person with a with a baby and that
drives I think that what drives a lot of
abortion is fear of losing your identity
or yourself
and that fear prevents you from taking
this leap from the you who you are now
to you as a mom but it's true that when
you have a baby your childless self will
perish the moment that child is born and
the new you that replaces the old you if
ever ran into the old you would say
thank God you did that and that is the
problem with abortion is there's this
separation between the before and the
after and you don't know you're wrong
until you cross that line
I think it's very brave of you to speak
on behalf of all women I was I was a
mansplaining but I don't care I get paid
to do it before me I just want to
just want him to represent Iowa in the
Senate she gets no props from Katie
Porter for that she's retired as a
lieutenant colonel in the National Guard
she served in the Iraq War and she's an
all-around badass woman so whoa wow
during the debate I thought you were
allowed to now yes yeah Greg's
definitely loosened the restraints on
that and you know if anybody wants to
throw mashed potatoes at me let's have
it how about hot cream come on how about
hot Siri I'll take it all you know what
and she's such a hypocrite she said she
was a victim of domestic violence she
slung the potatoes and she's the victim
yeah not how it works I wonder Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now